[Music]
it was a quick incursion into all oximos
compound under heavy Israeli security it
happened in the early hours of Tuesday
followed by a quick exit a calculated
intrusion with itamar Ben gavir making a
statement on this issue just days into
being sworn in as Israel's new national
security minister
our government will not surrender to the
threats of Hamas the Temple Mount is the
most important place for the people of
Israel and we maintain the freedom of
movement for Muslims and Christians but
Jews will also go and those who make
threats must be dealt with with an iron
fist
all it took was 13 minutes inside the
compound enough time to provoke
International condemnation including
from Jordan which oversees the holy site
it summoned the Israeli Ambassador in
protest while Palestinian leaders called
it an unprecedented provocation
the storming of Alexa mosque by the
Israeli Minister Ben gavier this morning
constitutes a serious challenge to the
feelings of the Palestinian people we
call on our people to confront such
incursions that aim to make Alexa mosque
a Jewish temple this is a violation of
all International Norms values
conventions laws and Israel's pledges to
the American president
we consider this cowardly attempt by Ben
gevir a dangerous escalation and a
provocation of the Palestinians and the
Arab and Muslim nations this could spark
a religious war in the region and this
statement from Israeli opposition leader
and former prime minister Yale appead
describing the intrusion as a
politically responsible decision and
showing incredible weakness from
Netanyahu in front of his ministers but
there was no mention of the incident in
the government's first cabinet meeting
while the prime minister's office
released the statement saying Benjamin
Netanyahu is committed to the status quo
's compound is the third holiest site
for Muslims but it's also revered by
Jews under the rules only Muslim worship
is allowed Palestinians though are
concerned that Ben gevis incursion could
set a precedent for Israel's new
Administration
the new ultra-orthodox and right-wing
government has promised to expand
illegal settlements in the occupied West
Bank where on Tuesday Israeli forces
carried out several raids at a refugee
camp near Bethlehem killing 15 year old
Palestinian Adam Hayer during
confrontations
bringing this year's Palestinian death
toll to three
this raid is the latest in a string of
more than 40 arrests made in several
Palestinian towns since the start of the
year a letter was placed on edamame's
coffin his family says he wrote it as a
message to the world in case of his
death that he's proud to be Palestinian
occupied East Jerusalem